so what some Marvel fans thought wasn't
possible isn't possible could never be
possible turns out could actually be
possible and we are talking about old
Marvel characters from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe who are no longer
there coming back and not as variants in
a different Universe although that is
definitely possible but today we are
talking about them returning for good in
a main Marvel Cinematic Universe so yes
we are talking about Robert Downey Jr
Scarlett Johansson Chris Evans talking
about the possibility of them returning
this is coming from a new report from a
very credible Source many of you might
have heard by now about the book MCU the
reign of Marvel Studios written by
Joanna Robinson Dave Gonzalez and Gavin
Edwards and according to Joanna Robinson
she says that Kevin fige could bring
back people who you thought were gone
forever speaking about characters in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe of course
here's the deal deal though this isn't
just going to happen in the MCU that we
have right now and currently no but this
is all going to come after Avenger
Secret Wars and after the soft reboot of
the MCU now we've been talking about the
possibility of a reboot for a little
while now and now it seems like it's all
but confirmed especially with Joanna
Robinson the author of MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios speaking out about what
she heard from Kevin feige recently she
was interviewed on a podcast called The
Watch she was being interviewed for the
book of course and she said this on the
interview and I quote we have a quote
from Kevin fugy sort of implying that
like Secret Wars will serve as a soft
reboot in which they can prune
everything that's not to use a lism
prune everything that's not working and
just keep what is working or bring back
people you thought were gone forever now
we have an idea of how this is actually
going to happen but first let's talk
about what some other insiders have said
in regards to the reboot as well because
many are actually saying the same thing
insiders my time to shine hello and can
we get some toast tweeted about Deadpool
3 and a soft reboot last month can we
get some toast specifically said this
yes Hugh Jackman won't be recast until
after Avengers Secret Wars feige is
making secret Wars the sendoff to not
only the current MCU but all the Marvel
movies that came before Iron Man it's
the ultimate soft reboot to make way for
something all new and all different and
they included a picture of a bunch of
different Marvel heroes that states on
top all new all different with Iron Man
at the front with Falcon there with
Captain America there black panther
spidergwen Spider-Man we won't dig too
deep into the picture but Iron Man is at
the front and now we have Joanna
Robinson stating that Kevin foggy could
have intentions to bring back people
that we thought were gone forever and
really only a handful of people come to
mind when we think about about bringing
back people who we thought were gone
forever Iron Man Black Widow Captain
America now why would Marvel Studios do
this well it is worth noting that in the
book MCU the reign of Marvel Studios
they did note that Kevin fagy had plans
for after Avengers ingame to sort of
replace the main characters of the MCU
because they knew Black Widow Iron Man
and Captain America were leaving and
this was their plan to replace them they
were going to make Spider-Man Black
Panther and Captain Marvel the new faces
of the MCU however that came with a lot
of problems in regards to Spider-Man
they ran into the whole Sony contract or
deal and for a while we did not know if
Spider-Man was going to stick around in
the MCU then with black panther of
course the unfortunate passing of
Chadwick Boseman and with Captain Marvel
well we all know the hate that Captain
Marvel and Brie Larson gets so all of a
sudden Marvel Studios had a plan that no
longer was a very good plan and couldn't
actually be executed due to the
unfortunate events that happened and
going forward in the MCU right now there
isn't really a face associated with it
you can't say there's one main character
of the MCU right now you could argue
Doctor Strange or you could argue Loki
but for the most part everything's been
pretty separated but with a reboot
coming that changes things because that
essentially lets you start from ground
zero and you can do this in a way that
actually does work and it works because
of the story of Avengers secret War and
essentially the story of the entire
Multiverse Saga our main Marvel
Cinematic Universe that we've known from
the very start since Tony Stark became
Iron Man in 2008 our 616 universe as we
call it is going to be destroyed it's
going to die it's going to be wiped out
whatever you want to call it it seems
like the destruction and the end of it
is getting closer as we get closer to
Avengers Secret Wars and here's how we
believe it's going to happen based off
of what we've heard about Deadpool 3 a
major plot point of that film film is
going to be the TVA monitoring the
Multiverse realizing that all of these
universes are being destroyed and them
starting to intervene and the way
they're going to intervene is what we've
been talking about a lot on the channel
recently and that is by them going into
these universes and taking heroes from
them saving them and bringing them to
another Universe a stable Universe
possibly even at the TVA itself we know
there's a huge City in the TVA that we
have not explored yet but bottom line
the TVA is going to be going across the
Multiverse saving a bunch of different
Heroes and eventually those heroes are
going to be kind of the heroes that we
see in Avengers Secret Wars this will
consist of Heroes from our main Earth
616 Universe maybe the 838 universe that
we saw and of course one of the big ones
is the fox X-Men Universe keep in mind
we've been told Deadpool 3 leads
directly into Avengers Secret Wars not
into King Dynasty but Secret Wars but
the big question is what happens after
Secret Wars if all of these un universes
have been destroyed how do they proceed
from there well it kind of sounds like
the option is to pick a new universe
that hasn't been destroyed and kind of
put everybody in it or if there are a
few universes that haven't been
destroyed spread out the heroes
throughout a few different universes
either way it's a new universe to us the
viewers and it's a new universe to the
people who come from our 616 universe
and from there basically anything is
possible you can go into that universe
and it could pretty much be an exact
replica with a few minor changes of the
universe that we've known and loved
since 2008 Robert Downey Jr could be
Iron Man in that universe or they could
go into that Universe prior to Tony
Stark becoming Iron Man they could
actually appear in the early 1900s or
the late 1900s or the early 2000s or
perhaps maybe even in the future the
point being anything is literally
possible including the return of Robert
Downey Jr as Iron Man Scarlett Johansson
as Black Widow and Chris Evans as
Captain America the only only question
is will the actors actually want to do
this and there could be appeal for some
a lot of people have argued that outside
of their Marvel roles some of the Marvel
actors haven't went on to do much more
nothing as big nothing as great which
Avengers endgame was the biggest movie
of all time at the time before Avatar
re-released in theaters so of course
nothing's really ever going to be bigger
than that but would the actors want to
return to the MCU well we all know how
good Kevin fige is at his job and coming
up with very creative stories and we
also know that money can change things
so Kevin fige and Marvel have the ideas
and the money to throw at these actors
the only question is will it be enough
money and can he be persuasive enough to
convince one two or all of them to
return and essentially start over so in
the beginning when I said they wouldn't
actually be variants I guess that was a
little off there they would be variants
since we would be in another universe
but they're not variants that would just
come in for a quick Cameo they would
stay this would be for another multiple
many years which is also another
consideration for the actors would they
want to devote another 5 to 10 years
playing the same role although the roles
would be slightly different and they
could make things different in this
other universe so the roles could be
quite fun also just want to add that
this is kind of a good opportunity with
a soft reboot for Marvel Studios to
actually recast to Chala I know a lot of
people have wished that they would have
just recast him right away but I think
we all understand where Marvel was
coming from trying to be considerate of
Chadwick boseman's death whether it was
the right call or not we understand what
they were trying to do however with a
reboot this gives them a completely new
opportunity to Simply recast him bring a
new tchala into the MCU it's also worth
noting that this is indeed going to be a
soft reboot and not everything that we
know not everyone that we know from our
universe is going to go away essentially
Kevin VY can pick and choose or like
Joanna Robinson said prune everything
that's not working and just keep what is
is working so quite honestly there's a
lot of really great potential here that
could come with a soft reboot of
Avengers Secret Wars but go ahead and
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below do you think it
would be a good idea or a bad idea to
bring back some of the original Avengers
and do you think the actors Robert
Downey Jr Scarlet Johansson Chris Evans
would want to return let us know all of
your thoughts about this down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month you can also find
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof